what is a faith-based system or a
religious system it's a system where you
could espouse otherwise illogical
beliefs right logic and reason could not
lead you to these beliefs but it has to
be a different way of believing them
that's what we as a human being have a
need for we have a need to have beliefs
that defy logic
and so if it's not going to be grounded
in belief in a traditional religion
belief in God
even belief in a nation a commitment to
a nation is not something that flows out
of logic flows out of something that we
as human beings have a desire for of a
need for something bigger than ourselves
we're going to channel that impulse to
something else
but the problem and this is the danger
of it is not that it's not the
time-tested faiths
it's the fact that we then trick
ourselves into thinking that it isn't
Faith at all right because when you go
to church you know what you're doing
right you go to a temple you know what
you're doing you're praying to God
you're exercising a side of your brain
that's different than that which you're
exercising if you're pouring chemicals
in a lab and measuring things
but I think what's happened is in
absence of traditional faith and
traditional beliefs where we recognize
that we're exercising our faith to
believe in these things we see the rise
of new secular religions secular Cults
instead which we fail to recognize are
actually religious belief systems
exactly like the climate belief system
and I think the most dangerous religions
are the ones that we fare fail to
recognize
as religions in the first place and
delude ourselves into thinking that it's
actually logic or reason that led us
there exactly that's exactly what's
happening in the country today well
there's a few things I'd say in response
to that firstly ultimately I do agree
with the point that these ideological
systems are more or less religions but
rather than having a personal God they
have a much more abstract God and it
generally ends up boiling down to a form
of self-worship usually but I would push
back against one part of this I agree
that there are many religious systems
where the faith does conflict with
reason I don't believe faith has to
conflict with reason and I would say
part of what's so Insidious about this
kind of left-wing cult we're seeing in a
lot of these bizarre new ideas is it
directly does conflict with reason I
think there are elements within divine
revelation that a person could not have
reason to on their own but it doesn't
contradict reason or or it's not asking
you to accept something which is like
completely and totally absurd such as
your biological sex can change on a
daily basis it it gives you ideally the
tools and this isn't it's singular
purpose but it does give you the tools
if it's the the right system to interact
with the world in a way which is
actually productive and helpful in these
new kind of cultist beliefs don't so I
would definitely agree with you on that
second part yeah I think we actually
agree on the whole part because
the religious belief systems don't have
to conflict with reasons of course they
don't
and so what I said is a cult is a
religious belief system that is not
withstood the test of time part of
withstanding the test of time is that I
think you do
you withstand the test of time better if
it is compatible with reason it's not
totally incompatible with reason the
problem with these near-term Cults right
the same cult we talked about the
biological sex being fluid versus sex is
the person you're attracted to being
fixed call that the cult of lgbtqia plus
the cult of climate effectively says
that
carbon emissions are bad if they come
from the United States but not if
they're coming from exactly you can't
believe those two things at the same
time and so it's the religions that
haven't withstood the test of time that
are the ones that actually run most
contrary to logic and reasons when it
comes to like climate science I don't
think it's unreasonable to think that
humans could destroy the Earth's
atmosphere we easily could nuclear war
is one way to do it we could do a lot of
ways comets could destroy the Earth's
atmosphere but what's unreasonable is to
tell people they have to stop producing
waste and that's the way to solve it
like people are gonna poop we're gonna
make waste we're gonna burn stuff to
stay warm so we need to figure out a way
not to stop I I believe it's
unreasonable to expect people to stop
producing the carbon dioxide and we have
to be reasonable about the climate we
need to reuse the waste this is why I'm
obsessed with pulling the carbon dioxide
out of the air it'll create another
climate crisis where we start to pull
too much carbon dioxide out of the air
and then we start to compete with the
trees and we need like a United Global
Coalition that's working together to not
pull too much methane and carbon dioxide
out of the atmosphere because that is a
valuable resource yeah it's well it's an
interesting idea I think kind of
touching on this this concept of old
ideas and new ideas that uh Vivek was
mentioning I'm curious Ian where you
sort of stand uh I I'll sort of launch
into my perspective on this but I've
talked about it before so I'm curious
where you are on this when someone says
this is a new idea or that idea is old
and conservative and retrograde what's
your response to that well what's an
example what do you mean well often
people will try to label liberalism and
conservatism as a war between old ideas
and new ideas and conservatives just
like the old ideas and liberals like new
ideas
oh geez well I mean we stand on the
shoulders of giants nothing's new we
have new data we can see things from
different perspectives with microscopes
and telescopes and things like when you
get a radio telescope and you see the
cosmic microwave background radiation
for instance it's this web of radiation
left over from The Big Bang out in the
universe it looks like a neural net like
that is God to me that is a evidence
that there is a God in our universe and
I've been agnostic my entire life but
when you see that how can you deny that
that is not sentient or that or that it
is I mean it is it is
functionably active so that's like an
old idea that is now seen in a new way
it doesn't have to be liberal or
conservative it's like we're just human
seeing seeing things from different
perspectives and if you can I don't know
maybe if you can accept that some people
don't quite don't see it the way you see
it it'll be a lot easier to convince
them well the way you see it I think
that's an interesting point uh obviously
I I would disagree with some of the the
spiritual proposals that you're making
there about the nature of the universe
but what I will say is I think you hit
the nail on the head when you said
there's nothing new uh and I firmly
believe this there's nothing new Under
the Sun and Vivek you described a cult
as a religion that has not passed the
test of time I think that that is a very
good way of describing it and it's
certainly a helpful way of understanding
it the way I've always sort of
conceptualized the you know war between
traditionalism and progressivism is not
that you have you know old ideas trying
to fight new ideas it's that you have
ideas that have stood the test of time
against ideas that have been tried and
have failed so many miserably that
people forgot about them and now they're
trying them again I think it's very
hubristic to say that man has been
thinking about such matters for
virtually all of human history and now
we've discovered something which is
totally unique and totally new I think
in terms of technological development
there are certain things we can discover
that are unique to our place and time
but when it comes to human moral
behavior these things are constants but
you know the problem and you mentioned
this too Vivek that the big problem
that's happening in the conservative
movement I see right now is that people
are screaming no at these things that
are rallying people in the liberal
whatever economic movement that are like
climate side whatever whatever and
rather than offer another idea it's just
no that's bad that's bad and that's
right it's not functional it's not that
inspiring and that doesn't move people
that doesn't move people towards
being the true version of themselves
they want to be which is what we all
hunger for and so you know what I said
left offers this narrative grounded in
race gender sexuality climate
well what I'm in this race doing
hopefully
is articulating in different Vision
grounded in the individual
the family
Nation
God Amen right so now you have a
different Vision we have competing
choices race gender sexuality climate
individual family Nation God at least
it's a different alternative Vision
which is what conservatism used to be
about it used to be about conserving
that's right those things right those
those pillars of human identity
why do we need those pillars of identity
you know the way I look at it is we are
in many ways like human beings the
analogy I would use we're like blind
bats
lost in a cave
trying to figure out where we are
how does a blind bat figure out where it
is sonar sonar echolocation right it
sends out signals so say we're in this
cave bounces off that wall it's
something that fixed it bounces back it
says this is where I am
let's I'm a human being I do the same
thing it bounce off that wall say my
family
the two parents mother and father who
brought me into this world that means
something to me that bounces back it
says this is where I am
sending out a signal that bounces off my
belief in God that is a true Faith to me
that balances back it tells me this is
where I am
off of my belief in this nation that I'm
a citizen of this nation not some
nebulous Global citizen somewhere but
that I'm a citizen of this nation in our
case the United States of America that
means something to me that bounces back
and says this is where I am I work hard
I create something in the world you make
music that's great whatever it is
that is real it is true that bounces
back I'm proud of that it tells me this
is where I am
what happens when those things each
disappear
we send out these signals
and then nothing comes back
and that's when we're lost in that abyss
and so we will latch on to anything
race gender sexuality climate
and and the conservative movement isn't
a bit of a paradox here because we're
supposed to be conserving something but
when the thing was supposed to be
conserving does not exist
now we have to be in the business of
actually recreating something or if it
was actually missing but the signal is
blocked or distorted because of
pharmaceuticals like 14 year olds on
Xanax or something crazy you can't
experience God properly if your mind is
tweaked by drugs I mean I don't think
you I don't think I don't think you can
have a healthy baby if you've got
amphetamines flushing through your
system like how can you even learn to
love if you hate if you're in pain from
from so not only is it if something is
missing but you need a clear mind what
do you think about colonizing Mars
this is not a topic we selected by the
way we're fine to talk about common
animals I'm in favor of exploration I'm
in favor of New Frontiers
I do think that there's a it's so should
particularly the United States of
America lead the way in establishing
roots on Mars absolutely I'd like to see
that
but I do think that it's an interesting
point I'm gonna tie to the discussion we
just had
there is a bit of escapism in that to
say that I'm going to find my sense of
meaning by going somewhere else when I
actually could have it right here at
home right yeah there isn't enough there
isn't anything we couldn't understand at
the atomic level that wouldn't be more
edifying and liberating for us that
would require us to go to Mars to do
instead I'm not denigrating the value of
going to Mars I would support it I think
as a spirit of human advancement and
human achievement and a down payment on
a future that's much longer than I
believe our past has been that's great
but I do
whatever the case may be I see one
serial substitute after another arising
saying that oh no maybe they think it's
going to give me fulfillment is going to
Mars yes it's that thing let's get
behind that
versus being grounded in the things that
have for most of our history grounded us
and given us meaning thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time